[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la une la
sécheresse qui inquiète si la situation
s'est quelque peu améliorée ces derniers
jours les cours d'eau restent
étroitement surveillés en martinique
vous verrez les coupures d'eau elles
s'enchaînent reportage devient occitanie
et devient à tv dès le début de ce
journal 100 jours de guerre et des
millions de réfugiés les ukrainiens
essaie tant bien que mal de se
reconstruire et de reconstruire leur vie
à l'étranger en moselle vous allez voir
une femme vient de se faire embaucher
dans un salon de coiffure un sujet de
moselle télévision avoir dans quelques
minutes meilleur ami de l'homme et son
sauveur aussi les chiens et leurs
capacités olfactives sont de plus en
plus utilisés lors de grands événements
pour assurer notre sécurité un reportage
lors du mythique grand prix de monaco
avec monaco info dans ce journal dans un
instant c'est une première en france un
train d'époque permet de relier deux
fort militaire du 19e siècle un voyage
aussi touristique qu'historique que nous
fera découvrir la rédaction de vosges
télévision en fin de journal
chaleur et sécheresse le pire est il à
craindre pour cet été alors que des
préfectures limite des jalles usages de
l'eau dans certains départements les
conditions climatiques qui reste
difficile en cette fin de printemps dans
les pyrénées orientales si la situation
n'est pas encore alarmante les cours
d'eau sont surveillés de très près par
l'office français de la biodiversité
regardez ce reportage d'isaac baril pour
vient occitane et sur place nous allons
donc observer l'écoulement de la rivière
surveiller les rivières pour prévenir de
la sécheresse l'office français de la
biodiversité surveille 33 cours d'eau
dans les pyrénées orientales de mai à
septembre la police de l'environnement
et aux aguets transmet c'est un autre
chef de service qui va donc compilé
toutes les données et qui va après
transmettre ça donc au préfet du
département pour donc prendre des
décisions quant à la prise d'arrêtés
près de préfectoral de sécheresse si la
sécheresse est constatée le préfet peut
alors prendre des mesures pour limiter
la consommation d'eau pour le moment il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir pour 2022
on est dans une année après donc on va
dire après 2021 ou l'année était
relativement sèche et et où il ya eu des
des arrêtés de restriction des usages de
l'eau assez important là sur 2022 on est
pas on n'est pas dans le dur en début de
saison ce qui n'empêche pas d'être
d'être vigilants l'inquiétant faisons
pour le département des
pyrénées-orientales le risque de
sécheresse est jugée fort pour cet été
il devrait en revanche rester faible sur
sept des 13 départements d'occitanie
la sécheresse un sujet d'inquiétude
aussi pour les départements d'outre-mer
en martinique les coupures d'eau se
multiplient depuis une dizaine de jours
en cause le manque depuis qui rend
difficile l'approvisionnement de
plusieurs réservoirs pour les
professionnels comme les restaurateurs
ces coupures récurrentes sont un vrai
défi au quotidien un reportage de robes
à paris c'est de marlène mecque pour
vient à tv en martinique
c'est l'heure de la plonge dans ce
restaurant de fort de france ce midi on
lave la vaisselle à la main et à
l'ancienne l'eau courante est coupée je
me trouve obligée de d'aller chercher de
sourdes haut en bas du restaurant où il
ya de l'eau les remonter et faire un
seau d'eau savognin seau d'eau l'eau
claire des coupures intempestives qui se
multipliaient depuis une dizaine de
jours ça peut venir aussi bien avant le
service le matin comme
l'après-midi ou le soir donc
à chaque service nous avons toujours une
surprise
de savoir si oui ou non on va voir de
l'eau une situation directement liés à
la sécheresse le manque d'eau rend
difficile l'approvisionnement des
réservoirs explique aude ici dans un
communiqué l'opérateur met en place des
coupures tournantes ici à cluny et dans
d'autres quartiers de fort-de-france
voilà le reste de l'actualité marquée
cette semaine par le triste symbole des
100 jours de guerre en ukraine les
troupes russes sont désormais
concentrées dans l'est du pays
au total presque 7 millions de personnes
ont fui ce pays depuis fin février parmi
eux plusieurs milliers vivent désormais
en france et tente difficilement de se
bâtir une nouvelle vie c'est le cas de
tatiana vous allez voir une ukrainienne
qui vient de se faire embaucher dans un
salon de coiffure en moselle un travail
en signe d'espoir pour elle reportage dé
ma fête chez ti pour moselle télévision
le bruit du sèche-cheveux a remplacé le
sont ahurissants des bombes à 35 ans
tatiana a laissé sa vie derrière elle en
février dernier la jeune femme a quitté
sa ville d'origine marine pool en
ukraine avec sa fille d'une amie
aujourd'hui elle tente de reprendre une
vie quasi normale en travaillant dans ce
salon de coiffure
j'ai décidé de trouver un travail parce
que c'est nécessaire pour moi pour
me sentir vivante de faire quelque chose
que j'aime parce que j'adore mon travail
c'est comme une chance pour moi
le monde de la coiffure cet univers
l'ukrainienne le connaît bien
puisqu'elle a 3 ans d'expérience en tant
que co lobbystes dans son pays un savoir
faire qui a conquis le coeur de la
gérante de ce salon alors je cherchais
une coiffeuse complète donc polyvalente
et tatiana menée elle est technicienne
elle ne s'est pas coupé fait un tout
petit peu les gros chine mais elle est
très demandeuse d'apprendre et moi je
veux bien la forme et même si les
coiffeurs et les clients du salon parle
très peu anglais l'ukrainienne arrive
tout de même à se faire comprendre grâce
à la technologie s'étonnera c'est la
couleur de prédateurs au niveau de la
barrière de la langue a aucun souci
puisque en fait en pratique avec le
portable ou simplement google traduction
et avec ça le tout si tout se passe bien
et puis on se fait comprendre fait
partie du milieu de la coiffure moi
aussi donc voilà on se comprend
facilement retourner en ukraine la jeune
femme y pense mais la situation de son
pays est encore trop effrayante pour
entreprendre un tel voyage
voilà et de l'espoir aussi pour des
enfants ukrainiens 17 mille d'entre eux
sont désormais scolarisés en france un
apprentissage forcément particulier dans
un nouveau pays pour eux et avec de
nouvelles habitudes à prendre alors
comment se déroulent leur scolarité à la
découverte du français par exemple
reportage d'angélique boilet dans un
collège du val d'oise qui accueille
depuis le mois d'avril neuf élèves issus
de plusieurs familles
ce matin-là ses cours de français pour
ces neuf élèves ukrainien ils ont fui
leur pays en guerre avec la russie et
sont scolarisés ici au collège robert
doisneau à gonesse depuis la mi avril
depuis leur arrivée ils ont entre 9 et
11 heures de français par semaine pas de
traducteur dans la classe le professeur
qui ne parle pas non plus l'ukrainien a
donc beaucoup recours à la gestuelle
ils sont intégrés dans le dispositif
prévu par l'éducation nationale appelée
eu pe2 à est destiné aux élèves
nouvellement arrivés en france dit
allophones un dispositif qui leur permet
de bénéficier d'un enseignement renforcé
en france elle en seconde avec un
professeur formé pour l'instant ils
suivent quelques matières comme les
mathématiques l'éducation musicale l'art
plastique ou encore l'anglais des heures
de cours classiques voué à augmenter au
fur et à mesure de leurs progrès
lorsqu'ils arrivent ils sont dans le
groupe un des grands débutants donc
c'est là où un nombre d'heures
conséquent de français langue seconde et
lorsqu'ils sont pris ils passent dans le
groupe 2 donc là forcément ils ont moins
d'heures de français langue seconde et
plus d'heures d'inclusion en classe
ordinaire on fait en sorte de les
accompagner pour qu'ils sortent de plus
en plus autonome c'est un suivi l'acquis
individuel au niveau des élèves et à à
terme ils doivent se retrouver en classe
ordinaire et a prévalu et comme les
autres élèves cela voudra dire qu'on
aura eu réussi cette mission justement
de
d'intégration après quelques semaines
d'apprentissage du français andriana ce
sont déjà plus à l'aise au début je
pensais que mon intégration serait
compliqué concernant l'apprentissage de
la langue française mais finalement je
trouve que je m'en sors bien pointe de
je trouve que c'est une langue
intéressante à apprendre
j'aime bien la l'école je suis contente
d'avoir cette chance
ces élèves ont également du temps libre
dans leur emploi du temps pour suivre
une partie du programme scolaire de leur
pays grâce à une plate forme en ligne
près de 17000 enfants ukrainiens sont
actuellement scolarisés en france
environ 1300 dans l'académie de
versailles
la guerre en ukraine qui était également
au centre des discussions lors de
l'émission face aux territoires diffusé
jeudi dernier sur tv5 monde
christian cambon sénateur et président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées du
sénat était l'invité de l'émission
regardez cet extrait avant c'était ce
que l'on appelle couramment l'état de
paix puisque nous sommes passés en
l'espace de quelques mois à l'état de
guerre en tous les cas dans la situation
du monde l'état de paix quelles
conséquences la hutte moi j'ai assez
j'ai participé à la précédente loi de
programmation militaire où effectivement
le raisonnement des dirigeants de droite
et de gauche de toute sensibilité
consisté à dire puisque ça fait plus de
70 ans qu'on ne connaît pas la guerre on
va pas dépenser des milliards pour
entasser par exemple des munitions qui
sont obligés d'être changées au bout de
2 5 à 10 ans et donc on va constituer un
stock raisonnable mais les faits
concrets ça a été de procéder à ce que
un ancien chef d'état major des armées a
appelé l'éreintement de nos forces
armées et et dire qu'on était arrivé à
une situation où par exemple près de 50%
nos hélicoptères ne fait pas décoller
faute de pièces de rechange faute de
formation à la ruse de ce pilote
disponible à la russe je laisse cette
affirmation jeu mais je pense
effectivement qu'il ya quelque chose
d'assez semblables face aux territoires
avec christian cambon est à voir ou à
revoir sur les sites internet de nos
partenaires ouest france nice matin et
vingt minutes sans transition être
livrés en un temps record et sans retard
c'est la nouvelle règle du commerce en
ligne l'exigence des consommateurs
complique néanmoins la tâche des
transporteurs soumis à davantage de
pression pour relever le défi de la
livraison express certains
professionnels développent des services
la nuit ou en horaires décalés vous
allez voir les colis arrivent à l'heure
et vous allez voir c'est aussi plus
écologique exemple à marseille avec ce
sujet de christophe rigaud
il est 18h dans ce dépôt logistique de
pièces automobiles de marseille ces
colis seront tous livrés dans la nuit
agathe béziers ou dans le rhône ces
livraisons en horaires de nuit sont une
tendance lourde du transport express et
dans cette entreprise du secteur on l'a
bien compris car livré en journée est
souvent synonyme de casse tête vous avez
tous les livreurs qui arrivent en même
temps ça sature la circulation ça prend
du temps
c'est pas très heureux c'est pas trés
rationaliser donc de ce constat simple
nous sommes mais évidemment des créneaux
libres sont la nuit
il est un peu plus de 4 heures du matin
en banlieue d'aix en provence et
sébastien arrive de lyon il a roulé
toute la nuit pour livrer ce grossiste
en pièces autos des horaires décalés qui
sont un vrai plus pour ce chauffeur on
n'a pas les problèmes de la journée que
ce soit des bouchons les accidents y en
a moins et on peut être plus précis au
niveau des livraisons de son
organisation de de tout ça quoi c'est
plus simple beaucoup moins de soins et
ceux et j'ai fait de la journée et ça
rien à voir
les livraisons de nuit réduisent
considérablement les temps de parcours
les risques de retard mais elles sont
aussi plus écologique le camion est
toujours en marche donc on n'est pas on
n'est pas arrêté nous on estime le
bénéfice à environ 20 % de gain co2 en
moins sur les trajets sur la
distribution et quand nous produisons
nos bilans carbone à nous à nos clients
effectivement ça nous permet de le
renommer vertueux les colis de sébastien
déposé cette nuit se récupérer dans ce
sas sécurisés au petit matin un mode de
livraison très apprécié par ce
professionnel au plus tôt on va être
livré au plus tôt on pourra servir le
client en général le professionnel le
garagiste s'il va avoir une peau bloqué
pour une pièce qui arrive à 10 ou 11
heures c'est pas intéressante pour lui
donc avoir trouvé la bonne solution en
étant livrés très tôt et pour voir
livrer le client dès 8 heures du matin
dès son ouverture c'est une gaine de
tentes pour lui est une solution pour
avoir sa bonne place au bon moment avec
le boom du commerce sur internet le
secteur de la livraison a augmenté de 47
% en deux ans une forte croissance qui
devrait voir la livraison en horaires
décalés se généraliser
sur la route une autre révolution est en
marche celle de la chaussée a nantes des
travaux sont actuellement en cours pour
la pose d'une route démontable c'est une
première en france cette voie façon
puzzle facilitera notamment les
interventions futures sur la voirie et
permet déjà de réduire le bruit du
trafic c'est tout à fait innovant les
explications avec ce reportage de
télénantes regarder
ces travaux quartier malakoff vont faire
naître une route d'un nouveau genre une
route en kit
la première en france né d'un
partenariat entre l'université gustave
eiffel eiffage et nantes métropole une
chaussée démontable qui offre de
nombreux avantages notamment lors
d'interventions sur les réseaux
souterrains quand on a besoin
d'intervenir ultérieurement sur les
réseaux on n'a pas besoin de venir faire
des tranchées de venir apporter de
l'europe et supplémentaires avec des
transports des matériaux supplémentaires
on a juste à démonter intervenir c'est
les réseaux et remonter donc le tout en
une journée donc avec une gêne moindre
pour les pour les riverains une
structure en dalle de béton qui aura la
particularité d'être poreuse on a une
chaussée qui a permet d'absorber la
pluie quand il va y avoir des grosses
verse dans ça évite de glisser pour les
véhicules ça évite de glisser pour les
vélos aussi ça évite que les aspersions
pour les piétons et puis également le
fait d'être pour eux ça permet
d'absorber le bruit et d'être moins
gênant pour la population avoisinant
l'eau ainsi récupérée pourra également
être réutilisés pour arroser les espaces
verts en 2008 un prototype a été
installé au centre technique de la
janvraie chaque jour une trentaine de
poids lourds patients cette dalle un
test grandeur nature conclut en fait on
est dans un centre technique mais
finalement ça se rapproche des voix
qu'on peut trouver sur l'espace public
donc avec des interventions successives
de réseaux qui ont fait que il ya eu des
tranchées donc avec des morceaux de
robes et de couleurs différentes qui
vieillissent différemment et puis on a
une zone beaucoup plus homogène qui est
la chaussée urbaine démontable on voit
visuellement le résultat donc on
améliore quand même la qualité
esthétique de nos voire plus cher à la
construction mais beaucoup moins en
maintenance par rapport une route
classique une chaussée démontable peut
être rentabilisé en une trentaine
d'années
et transport et beaucoup d'autres sujets
sont à découvrir dans l'édition spéciale
de l'hebdomadaire le point cette semaine
consacrée à la ville de nice au sommaire
de ce numéro notamment des informations
exclusives sur le nouveau port de la
ville ou encore les perspectives
touristiques avec un était impacté par
la guerre donné par la russie en ukraine
le point qui consacre aussi vous le
voyez une édition spéciale cette semaine
à toulouse la ville rose qui a su
rebondir selon l'hebdomadaire avec un
dossier dédié aux champions de la
relance l'actualité politique enfin avec
les élections législatives et un article
sur les ambitions de la présidente de la
région occitanie carole delga sans
transition dans ce journal intéressons
nous maintenant à une méthode innovante
pour éviter la prolifération des rats en
ville le déploiement de l'un de ces
prédateurs notamment le furet la
technique est notamment utilisée depuis
peu à limoges et s'avère efficace dans
les zones les plus sensibles comme les
bas d'immeuble où s'accumulent parfois
déchets et poubelles écoutez ces
précisions recueillies par alain druon
de la chaîne locale sur place 7 à
limoges
c'est pas un travail pour un jeu qu'ils
aiment ça ils aiment se balader et ça
c'est bon on espère par cette opération
un petit peu exemplaire
faire comprendre l'importance de la
propreté des pieds d'immeubles pour
réussir à conjuguer et à maîtriser la
prolifération le rail a toujours été là
depuis des siècles on veut pas
l'éliminer l'éradiquer ou juste le
maîtriser
il est dit-on le meilleur ami de l'homme
le chien en plus d'être un fidèle
compagnon peut aussi sauver des vies
muzeau et flers vous le savez lui
permettent de détecter des odeurs ou des
substances illégales même dans un
environnement hostile des compétences
extraordinaires de plus en plus
exploitée lors de grands événements
comme le grand prix de formule 1 de
monaco par exemple chiens et des mineurs
un reportage de la rédaction de monaco
info
prénommé pirates ce berger allemand est
doté d'un flair infaillible
ils traquent tout engin explosif qui
pourrait être disséminé durant le grand
prix de formule un membre à part entière
d'une équipe de démineurs venus de la
france entière ce chien a accompli une
formation de 14 semaines avant d'être
détecté pour le terrain ce n'est que du
jeu le chien est en quête de sa poupée
dans le petit bout de tissu que je vous
ai montré tout à l'heure et en fait lui
dans sa tête son travail c'est de
chercher sa poupée aucunement aux
drogues le chien par des explosifs par
des produits stupéfiants ce que vous
voulez et toujours dans la bonne humeur
c'est que le chien voilà c'est là c'est
la joie c'est la compagnie
l'accomplissement de la tâche
donc c'est une coupe et qui est au
contact d'un explosif
on le fait travailler dessus et le chien
assimile les deux les chiens font partie
intégrante des opérations de déminage
dont l'efficacité repose sur la synergie
entre l'homme et l'animal un roulement
est opérée entre au plusieurs chiens le
repos est primordial pour un meilleur
accomplissement de leur mission ces 20
minutes de travail pour quarante minutes
de repos mais la voyez que ce matin il
fait déjà très chaud et en fait les
chiens sont rapidement aussi puisque
quand il est en page la phase de pompage
c'est tout le fonction c'est à dire que
le chien inspire toutes les molécules
dans l'environnement durant les quatre
jours de course tous les matins une
ronde est effectuée en collaboration
avec les équipes de démineurs du palais
princier si un chien détecte quelque
chose de suspect une procédure est
directement enclenchée si un premier
chien un comportement qui nous inquiète
du coup on fait passer un deuxième chien
qui confirmera ou infirmera le l'effet
du premier si bien sûr et confirme on va
pas chercher plus loin c'est pour nous
c'est probant il se passe quelque chose
alors ça peut être un simple et un sac
et maculées d'une certaine matière est
parfois tout bêtement ça peut être
quelqu'un qui a fait du tir sportif
voilà qui a utilisé le sac il l'a posée
à la tribune il l'a oublié il a pas fait
attention le chien le détecte puisqu'en
fait ils prennent la poudre la poudre
noire donc là du coup sécurisation
périmètre de sécurité avia autorités et
ce n'est qu'à ce moment là
qu'interviennent et des mineurs puisque
nous on n'est pas dans les pas des
mineurs au sens strict du mot ces chiens
démineurs forme avec leurs maîtres une
véritable équipe qui permet de
travailler en toute sécurité
voilà et du grand prix de formule 1 de
monaco passons aux championnats de
france radio commandé une des manches de
cette compétition était organisée il ya
quelques jours et si ces petits bolides
ne font pas le même bruit que leur très
grande soeur de la f1 il n'en reste pas
moins performants précisé au micro de
marc antoine michelli de la rédaction de
vie à télévisé sur place en corse ont
beaucoup de l'entraînement beaucoup de
minutie sur la mécanique
c'est très très important la mécanique
c'est essentiel de bien savoir régler sa
voiture et après le pilotage ça vient
avec l'entraînement
c'est une tendance qui commence à se
pérenniser le nombre d'exposants ne
cesse d'augmenter dans les vide greniers
depuis le confinement et les clients
répondent aussi à l'offre vous allez
voir avec la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
le vide grenier est devenu l'endroit
idéal pour dénicher les bonnes affaires
et lutter contre le gaspillage exemple
dans la loire avec adrien bletterie de
la rédaction locale de tl7 la télévision
de la loire
des vêtements des fioles des sacs
poubelles ici c'est une vraie caverne
d'ali baba alors là j'ai un petit peu
tout bas j'ai des livres anciens la
peluche les chaussures dévoile un petit
peu de luminaires et ça se voit que ça
marche sur les 1600 mètres carrés de
surface 90 % des stands sont occupés par
des exposants qui pense beaucoup à la
seconde c'est surtout d'éviter le
gaspillage parce que ça fait mal au
coeur de jeter à la poubelle tous ces
objets et puis l'argent qu'on récupère
mais ça permettra d'offrir d'autres
choses aux petits puisqu'on a surtout
vendu des joies qui n'utilisent plus un
stand sur le nouvel ici tous les mois il
faut donc régulièrement changer ses
produits trouver les bons prix un vrai
travail au quotidien pour beaucoup
d'exposants c'est la différence d'un
dépôt-vente c'est eux qui du coup choisi
ce qu'ils veulent mais trait aux prix
auxquels ils veulent le mettre c'est
cette petite particularité là que les
gens aiment bien quoi une particularité
qui se ressent aussi dans la plaine avec
les puces mars illinoise qui rassemble
chaque année plus de 2500 exposants et
un certain nombre de bénévoles parfois
nombreux le matin qui les accueille pour
les placer voyait dans ces années là on
a faim on fait un traçage une grosse
attente vis-à-vis des puces non
seulement par les amateurs il ya des
gens qui aiment bien chine et mais il y
en a d'autres qui en ont besoin et donc
soit parce que ils ont des affaires à
vendre pour des raisons économiques
et puis ça permet de donner aussi
plusieurs vie aux objets ce vide grenier
est une véritable institution dans le
forez il existe depuis 1999 il se tient
chaque dimanche de début mai à fin
septembre un endroit incontournable pour
les chineurs et les exposants des
exposants qui doivent d'ailleurs faire
attention à la loi car il est interdit
d' participez à une brocante ou un vide
greniers plus de deux fois par an
voilà ouvrant une page culture dans
cette édition avec la visite organisée
du château de versailles pour plus de
quatre mille collégiens des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine l'occasion pour eux
de découvrir l'emblématique château et
notamment la salle des glaces imaginé
par louis xiv et d'en savoir aussi un
peu plus sur les disciplines artistiques
de l'époque réaction au micro de nicolas
landry de la rédaction de télé 78 dans
les yvelines donc j'aime beaucoup cette
pièce avec tous ces miroirs etc race
j'aime beaucoup les tableaux on a montré
moi ce que je préfère c'est la salle des
glaces elle est immense moi qui ai
jamais visité le château de versailles
c'est vraiment magnifique je suis venu à
peu près au même âge visiter le château
de versailles avec mon école et on
n'oublie jamais ce qui m'a marqué sans
doute ce qu'il c'est d'arriver dans ce
château immense et d'être tout petit et
évidemment quand on grandit on pense
qu'il va prendre des dimensions plus
normal et ça n'est pas vrai maintenant
que je suis au château de versailles je
sais que ça reste un très grand château
près de 2000 visiteurs et 250 oeuvres
exposées la deuxième édition de la foire
meinhardt art s'est tenu fin mai à paris
ce rendez vous consacré exclusivement à
l'art du moyen-orient et d'afrique du
nord a permis de mettre en avant le
travail d'une centaine d'artistes et
l'effervescence culturelle d'une région
du monde encore méconnu en europe le
prochain rendez vous culturel
représentatives de l'art du moyen orient
et de l'afrique du nord est prévue en
janvier prochain à bruxelles allez on
referme ce journal avec un train
touristique et historique dans les
vosges cette partie du territoire est
constellée vous le savez peut-être de
fort militaire datant du 19e siècle
finalement très peu utilisé ces sites
représentent désormais un atout
touristique pour la région près d'epinal
deux d'entre eux sont dorénavant relié
par un petit rat d'époque remis sur les
rails par des bénévoles passionnés une
première en france un reportage
d'anthony sap et de tirer la leçon pour
vosges télévision
attention au départ après plus de 15 ans
de travaux le train d'effort vous
propose un petit voyage dans l'histoire
de l'ancienne place forte d'epinal et
c'est une première en france la partie
fortifications n'intéresse pas
particulièrement ou hors des gens un peu
plus spécialisés mais là on sait que les
petits trains les gens adorent et c'est
leur faire connaître la fortification au
travers de l'aspect ferroviaire voilà un
outil d'attractivité touristique
indéniable pour le territoire et en
effet pour l'effort la grande passion
des bénévoles de l'afub qui anime le
site depuis 1989 et travaille depuis
près de deux décennies sur la
restauration de cette petite partie du
réseau ferroviaire stratégique créé il
ya 130 ans puis progressivement
démantelée ils y ont passé leurs
vacances leur week end mais aujourd'hui
le train relie à nouveau les deux forts
sur une distance de près de 2 km
difficile en revanche de connaître
précisément le coût global de ce
chantier qui s'étend sur plus de quinze
ans avec une main d'oeuvre bénévole du
matériel prêté ou récupérer on parle
tout de même d'un budget de 100 à 150
mille euros allégée par la fondation du
patrimoine toujours fidèle au poste on a
alloué près de 30000 euros et puis la
mif a abondé à 15000 euros ce qui fait
que en tout c'est une petite somme de
50000 euros qui a été versé plus de cent
ans après après la fin de la première
guerre mondiale mais il faut se
remémorer tous que ça a été les
difficultés les machines à vapeur et
donc effectivement on quand on prend le
tgv on n'a pas l'impression qu'on vient
d'une histoire très longue est ce
important de se rappeler sa est le mieux
pour cela c'est donc peut-être un petit
voyage en train entre l'effort du
grenier de bois l'abbé l'occasion de se
rappeler epinal et et en 1914 l'une des
quatre places fortes principal du
système défensif de la france avec
verdun toul et belfort
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]